[Music]
um look I've been I haven't done this
for a while because we not not for any
of the reason but because
we've been just getting into too much
stuff or whatever so
every time I was waiting for a day
Frozen's not here because Frozen cannot
handle this anymore yeah it really bugs
him and I don't blame him and I I have
like okay I've been amused by it because
it's like you know I don't want to get
Frozen man on purpose but he gets mad
but he never get I've never seen him be
a real [__] like actually like
explosive angry guy and this is one of
the few this is one of the only things
that triggers him well
I've been getting a lot of comments uh
we've been getting a lot of comments on
the clip Channel about uh we need more
date we need more Dayton so we got a
little update it's not huge but it's
something we've also been getting a lot
of comments like talk about the Jews you
don't guys talk about the Jews enough
say more true stuff and it was like okay
there was one guy it was Pepsi
repeatedly it was petty because he
forgot to log into his alt I know I
don't know what that's about you guys
are criticizing those [__] cakes
all right you could you could start the
clip here um yeah taper taper so uh
Dayton update here's what we have
title of this uh is my mom rarely speaks
to me has me downstairs to talk with my
ailing dad who is voids responding to
her now it's not that he avoids
responding to her dying yes I and let me
tell you something I and this is
something that I'm gonna say he's pretty
cool to see you at the hospital and
you're all hooked up to respirators and
[__] with it ventilator how are you
feeling bud
all right I mean drop the [__]
attitude though wow the silent treatment
wow
okay [__] I mean if you just sit
there at the Darth Vader impression all
night I guess I'll go to McDonald's so
um
this is him secretly recording his mom
um now I'm gonna say this right now the
one of the people that hook us up we
have multiple people now that hook us up
with the Dayton content on his Facebook
um you know they're called Heroes I'm
not gonna post it because I have actual
sympathy for this part but Dayton on his
Facebook posted a picture of his dad in
a hospital bed in the living room
downstairs like hook to stuff because
because he's a complaint but complaining
about he couldn't go out
and I'm like I'm not gonna post that
picture because I think that you should
have some dignity if you're passing away
okay I was saying it was going to be in
this video you posted like on Facebook
he does this he did on Facebook yeah
of his dad in a um
his dad in a uh he's the worst human
being right yeah ever
here hold on let me Jesus Christ
that's dark here here you go uh merch
what do you want me to I'll send it if
you want to see it what do you want me
to say Squad it's easier when I'm on
this computer all right here you go
this is one of them
and hold on there's another one coming
in
and this is the the second one's the one
that I'm definitely not gonna post but
he posted this on his
Facebook there you go
what the
man
oh I hate this [__] guy man yeah it's
not the best
um and guys look it's not because we're
trying to keep it's just I I mean you
should have some dignity there is yeah
man I'm sorry I have to have some
dignity we get called soft sometimes
maybe we're not as much as we were 10
years ago but
and he's using that well it gets crazy
so this is him [__] piece this is him
recording his mom
that's why is there Firefly Flynn house
playing music playing in the background
oh his mom [__] unless Jesus loves me
so it's like Christian music because you
know the dad's side
I swear to God I would that would be
torture if I was laying on my way oh
yeah I wouldn't want somebody especially
like that kind of Christian music where
it's the old timey that's children's
Christian Jars of Clay yeah it's yeah
well it's it's the it's the wheels on
the bus for Christmas and pod yeah I
wouldn't even be mad if you had some
P.O.D rocking while I was trying to all
right man it's my wake I'm up and it's
all right it's all right
once satellite comes on my [__] my my
beats per minute start going up they're
like maybe it's something here
[Music]
Alexa stop
can you play some Bauhaus or something
do you have anyone
just keep talking to him Earl he's your
dad
that's not his name it's Kate she dead
named him and that's the most important
thing going on right now in that home
the the best part is now he's going so
she's like yeah you can hear you he's
your dad talk to him I'm waiting here
Dad I need to use your credit card
and by the way the reason that this is
all dark is because he's hiding the
phone in his pocket it's secretly
recording his mom don't worry even if
your dad can't speak he can still hear
you all right so talk to him
so we're out of house burritos are you
gonna go or should I just use a car
should I go get it I don't like the food
if the hospital
no no I can't even talk to him
mom still hasn't paid me for like two
weeks I've been doing a lot of laundry
and so um
can you hear me
talk louder if you can't hear I think
you can hear more
oh my God oh my God this is oh my God
it's so creepy why don't you hold his
hand why would you record this because
he's it's look how long the video is and
he's gonna record this and like
he'll he'll play it back and the whole
time he'll be going [__] mom so let's
get ahead and beat me there's not gonna
be any emotional connection to like that
moment and being like Jesus like if
there was a video that existed if my
mom's like last few days I would I would
never watch it because I would it would
be like Jesus like you know like those
are emotions that are like but he won't
feel anything he'll just be like well
you know it's gonna brother beat me bro
what if bed's in the dining room so I'm
actually glad Frozen's not here he'd be
so [__] angry right now I'm trying to
make it funny but it's tough this is
rough no no it'll be this this and I I
front loaded the bad stuff there is some
stuff definitely some stuff to mock here
coming up in a second I just want to
give an update for people that generally
were asking like what's going on and as
far as the GoFundMe goes the family's
probably gonna do something but right
now for last I heard
they're dealing with this yeah you know
obviously and also from what I also
heard is like and this is true like
they're those type of people that don't
want welfare they don't want charity
they don't they they kind of feel bad
taking it yeah and you can kind of tell
that's the way they are
well if it makes them feel any better
we're not giving you a handout we're not
giving you a charity based on your
husband dying we're doing it for all the
years you had to deal with Earl that
exactly that's nothing to do with this
this is just a little payment to say
we're sorry it's like we do it in my
fast so my family it doesn't even speak
to each other they still show up to a
funeral with an envelope because they're
just old-time Grays balls yeah
my condolences yeah egos is
uh I mean you should talk to him he's
your dad
why'd you let him beat me in this house
you should talk to him he's your dad
your father's dying man you can't just
appease your mom for like five seconds
man you're you're really
that's I mean
I thought I thought like the deathbed
was like at least traditionally speaking
a deathbed was a place where you would
always go make peace with people even if
you hated their guts
like wasn't that always a [__] thing
like even if you were kind of like yeah
I would get it if you were like really
you know I'm not saying you would go to
your rapists deathbed or anything but I
just mean like people you had bad blood
with or whatever it's like you know the
whole point of this whole process is
that we sort of learned like oh yeah you
know life is precious you know what I'm
gonna go make peace with this guy while
he's you know still in the hospice or
whatever like I hate this guy
mm-hmm
go ahead and hold his hand and talk to
him who's your dad mom I I'm asking I
just asked that you speak calmly to me
at this time and um it's about him Mom
I'm dealing with a lot okay dad's dying
there's no Health burritos and I haven't
been paid in two weeks
oops this is
sorry I restart the here we go
okay cheer me out there's an hour and 17
minute video I've skimmed through this
video
um obviously obviously I haven't heard
everything yet I did not sit there in
this one now in 17 minutes they don't
have nowhere we were talking about this
before so I'm gonna ask you this just so
we could before we continue
do
you think
that we should download these videos so
people don't [__] with this YouTube
and give some of these videos to our
local subscribers like upload it to
logos directly so you have to be a
supporter to look at it for a couple
reasons number one after them skim
through it'll be a bigger group of
people going through I know there's gold
in here but none of us have time for an
hour inside only time but it's rough to
like you know what I mean if I'm trying
to drive like the gym or I'm trying to
get like [__] done between shows and
this is on in my car yeah it's just
gonna I'm gonna drive my own car into a
pole it's so depressing
uh
uh so here's what I'm gonna do
speaking of locals antithepie for 20 I
said making my Dono rounds to the RTC
groups used to have a frozen just have
Frozen left now P.S I'm not gay but I'd
eat Fergie's ass like Chipotle
nice Virgie you're in you're in Virgie
so here's what I'm gonna do is that a
dude or broad I think it's a dude okay
so have fun I think it's a dude it's all
you Verge funds in the mystery so I just
uh I just uh it's processing now I just
published for supporters only on Revenge
of the
sis.locals.com this entire one hour and
17 minute video
because I know people have been asking
for it so we figured okay
so I made a playlist now and I'm gonna
be adding some of these videos into this
playlist for the people that actually
want to see these videos
um and I know a lot of people have have
actually been asking for them so you
guys could grab them there
revenge of assist.locals.com something
one so don't repeat it
or if you're going to repeat it you know
don't just say it over and over this
she is is mom being as calm as humanly
possible here all my settings because I
yeah well why have you heard me heard me
say so far
well if you can't think of that and I'll
just calm down
Jesus is she being crazy calm down like
she has been a gem this whole time I'm
not gonna go over because I'm really
okay all right
[Music]
that's why I'm drawing my hands right
now
I know I just think we should both calm
now I just think we should pause
hey Earl can you talk to your father
please well calm down chill dude mom
relax mom you're being ridiculous mother
sounds like [__] it sounds like it
sounds like a couple on Xanax arguing
yeah hey hey calm down all right don't
attack me all right I'm just saying you
should probably do the thing all right
boys
calm down you're you're being crazy
you're acting just domestic violence on
Xanax you're acting just like your ex
oh
so
this is him the entire time we refuse to
talk I'm going to move on for this video
because there's more stuff than there's
this video so before we get into the
next video I want to show you this is at
the exact same time as the picture I
sent you of his dad in the hospital bed
yes of this video okay what I'm about to
show you this is from his Facebook page
the same day ready
this is his dating profile non-binary
located in uh day in Ohio
I bought condoms for the first time this
week since I think last summer and the
ones I bought before I never used this
house is just the best for sure not the
best not the best for economies you're
around with any room's temperature
getting too cold or hot and latex
getting brittle or stale anyway maybe
I'll find a day for Valentine's soon
I'm free of any STIs and SCD no lover
since
2009 this guy hasn't [__] since 2009
and you don't think maybe something's
wrong with you maybe the reason the
condoms are going bad is because they're
20 years old yeah seriously I mean they
you know they'll stay up for a little
while I mean even a little bit this is
the truth even a little bit past the
expiration date they still work uh I'm
uh and got uh and got tested anyway
since to received limited psoriasis
treatment whatever and here's his sexy
picture for he's looking remember he's
looking for Valentine's Day in case any
fellas are interested
um we have that and then have I also
have and by the way stop holding up the
Magnums like they're a brag they're
almost the same size as regular condoms
guys I'm gonna let you know a little
secret out there in life
um
regular sized condoms are mine
microscopically smaller than Magnums
um
if you can fit a regular condom on and
it's snug enough you can fit a magnum on
your deck and it's snug enough and the
Magnum thing is a [__] marketing
angle it's all it is Magnums are
marketing they're a little bigger but
they're not like oh my God if you have a
giant dick stronger still Magnums aren't
going out they're a little longer yeah
that's it um Magnums will fit any dick
but so they have to so get Magnums it's
a little tip out there I I know the
little trick he's trying to do like oh
my [__] dick ass but like it's
Magnums are regulars about regular
condoms they'll make your dick feel like
you're crisp and wanna Bowflex it's not
good it's not yes
you want to be you want to be something
in something really wet but your dick
stay bone dry yeah condoms
Kate paradoxia on his uh said about to
shower in a bit get ready to go to some
band show downtown tonight if anyone
wants to meet Valentine's pre weekend is
only a week from now free weekend it's
Valentine's free weekend is that like
the Road to WrestleMania it is it is
WWE access it's NXT Valentine takeover
yes when they do one the same weekend as
a [__] paper of WWE it's only a week
from now if anyone is deciding if they
want a Valentine and are single I don't
even want to think about next week and
if I'm not even dating anyone yet oh
well anyway I'm here looking I'm here uh
anyway here I am looking shabby before I
get it get into Glam Glam is he glamming
us he
in US
oh psoriasis this is gorgeous we just
got glammed shout out to super fun
wrestling time
Dorian Kade earlp yeah just glammed us
we got glammed
[__] that was a egregious flagrant clam
too he even said he was glaminous in it
that was like when you straight up grab
a football player by his [__] face
guard like in Plainview and you're like
what were you thinking
and then this is him recording his dad
he said Dad's down talks downstairs to
family friend about his alcoholics kids
said skinheads on a beam regularly this
is the same day as the other video these
things are all the same day before you
hit play because I want to take a step
back for one more second to the dating
profiles why is he like I know he's
trying to get laid whatever but what's
his obsession with Valentine's Day
you're old and you're single you stop
pretending to be a child this isn't
you're not Ralph Wiggum anymore and
nobody's gonna choose you all right so
[__] give it up and no one wants to
be friends no nobody even wants to be
friends with you
um so stop it stop me working this angle
you're so mentally [__] regressed
that you're like I don't have a date for
Valentine's Day with that's because
Valentine's Day is for couples you [__]
that's what it's for it's for couples
and for kids there's really no point to
have Valentine's Day when you're 30 like
I'm single looking for an eight for
Valentine's Day that's weird then get a
hooker
not on Valentine's Day they're more
expensive then
wait till the week after
I don't know do you think they I would
think more people have to be with their
women on Valentine's yes yes you're
right more people have to be with their
women and that is true but then there's
a lot of people that do not want to kill
themselves so they get a date on that
they get a hooker on Valentine's Day who
the [__]
wow that's a great sharp that's great
American Marketing when you're willing
to kill yourself because you don't have
a date on this pre-chos and stupid
Hallmark holiday for sure oh yeah I
guess I'm sad everybody's cuffing this
week I guess I'll kill myself Jesus
relax yeah I don't need a reason
give me one I don't even [__] am I
gonna do it over [__]
hold on any movie he goes right around
here
I decided to record this because my dad
is down there talking to filled out
drunk
in front of the families I think
sounds like anyways who knows I could
overhear him talking about
my skinhead older brother
before I even started recording this I
could hear him say something along those
I could hear him say that he um
I think I recorded out I heard that
it's just such a mess such a [__] up
mess of a family you mean you're dying
your dying father uh took a moment to
speak to a family member and say that he
missed and loved his dead son you know
that's really really sad that means what
a sick [__] that guy is you're right
your dad's a sick [__] yeah but like his
brother was a Nazi reminiscing him
reminiscing about his son who at least
tried his hand at boxing in a couple
failed businesses and you know a guy
that at least tried to live some kind of
a life the favorite son yeah no yeah
he's talking about him died like a man
from [__]
bruise failure
right now I can I heard her dinner like
well then she came downstairs or she
came into the house
around the same time Mom got home it
sounds like because I heard them talking
in the kitchen just now
so anyway it's just hearing that
my sister allowed all that violence to
happen to me but the skinhead my sister
remained completely neutral to it she
allowed it to psychologically mess her
up yeah you know what date I'm not gonna
sit here and have you repeat the same
thing over and over again we're not
going to go through this a million times
we're not doing this there's your Dayton
update if we have something new I will
bring it to you but I mean the rest of
this video is just him most egregious
was the [__] picture yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I was like when I saw that
even I was like this is this is
this is [__] gross you know
don't use them as a [__] prop you
piece of [__]
oh he's [__] garbage oh he's garbage